I'm John Nelson and I'm an assistant scoutmaster with Troop 947 in Westchester Ohio.
This addition to the Scoutmasters podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now it's the old scoutmaster.
Well, it's Thanksgiving week Now. not many of you know this, but years and years ago
I once tried my hand at turkey farming. Yeah, it really didn't go very well, though
Apparently I planted all the eggs too deep
Sometimes. sometimes people mistake our scouter meetings for a turkey farm,
but that's to be expected. Happy Thanksgiving everybody. This is podcast number 197.. Hey,
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. Hey, let's take a look at the
mailbag. It's a pretty full one. this week Donnie Grandy is with Boy Scout Pack and Troop 720
in Glen Allen, Virginia, And he wrote in to say this
back in podcast 120, you interviewed me about my son's beginning scouting. I remember that very
well, Donnie. a very touching story. Get back there to podcast 120 and listen to it if you
haven't already. He passed his Eagle Board of Review in September and his Eagle Court of Honor
is our December Troop Court of Honor. Thanks for your continued sharing on your website and
podcast. Thanks, Donnie, for getting in touch. That's great news and congratulations to your son
and yourself. Jeff Person is from Richland and he wrote in to say 196 and counting. I have enjoyed
all the past podcasts. Congratulations and many thanks. Looking forward to 197 and 98 and 99
and 200 and on. You've really jumped into the volcano. Listen, if you don't know what jumping
into the volcano means, well, I'm not going to try and explain it to you, but you get the idea
right. Your passion for scouting shows. I've changed hats from Scoutmaster to Council Training Chair
and plan on continuing to listen to the podcast and frequent the website.
I will continue encouraging others to do the same. Thanks, Jeff, So nice of you to be in touch
and thanks so much for listening. David Goldenberg is Scoutmaster of Troop 22 in Western Los Angeles
and he says thanks for the shout out on the backer program. Dave Goldenberg is my evil twin,
but it's all good. I've got assistant Scoutmasters in our troop listening in
and I had a phone call the other day after one heard my name As a new Scoutmaster.
your words of wisdom are helping me validate our program and keep making some changes to keep
up the great work. Well, thank you, David. Maybe they'll call you this time and let you know. I
actually got your name right. Charles Bachman is in Point Sienna, Florida, and he wrote in to say
I think your site is great and I use it as a reference to Scouters in the district
and to our commissioning staff to share with their units. I'm a assistant district commissioner
and a unit commissioner and a special needs scout specialist. I've been enjoying Scouting for the
past 39 years and counting. I wasn't involved for a little while until about three years ago.
my grandson asked his mother if he could attend school night for Scouting. She said: go talk to
your grandfather. He was in Scouting for many years. What could I say? I couldn't refuse
my grandson, nor did I want to. I had a smile and tears at the same time. He's now in Weebelo's one
and loves Scouting. There's been a great deal of change in the program since I was last involved
and there's a great deal more for Scouts. I've been working with one Troop's junior leadership
and they built their Troop up exponentially. I just heard from our scout executive who's been
getting phone calls from parents of youth that just joined that Troop. They can't believe their
boys are now running the Troop and the program to accomplish their advancement. Again, thank you,
Mr Green, for all you do. I'm now working on 40 years and, with God's help, I will continue.
Well, thank you, Charles, for getting in touch and thanks for your message of encouragement.
It's wonderful that you're enjoying Scouting with your grandson. and you know, old-timer,
you got me beat by about 10 years. I'll hope I'll be able to say I've been involved for
40 years someday. Scott Galletta is with Troop 651 in San Marcos, California, and he wrote in to say:
I was listening to your last podcast on the way to work, with the return of the infamous
penguins paddling a canoe in the desert Joke, quote unquote. That night on my way home
I decided I would listen to an old podcast and I hit the randomizer on my iPhone.
They have a randomizer. How about that? The podcast? gods must have a sense of humor because
I got podcast number 31 with the original telling of the aforementioned quote, joke unquote.
Maybe I need to work on my karma. I just became a backer and I look forward to the new book.
As always, the podcast and site are great and I'm constantly directing other adults and even
our older youth to take a look. Keep up the good work and I'll keep tuning in. Scott,
that's a bargain. Thanks for getting in touch and thank you so much for becoming a backer.
Scott Pulaski is with Troop 778 in Wood River, Illinois and he says, first off,
thanks for everything you do for scouting and the education of our leadership. I have
a not so simple website suggestion. As new leaders come in and find your podcast archive,
would it be possible to create a download of all the episodes at once? It's just a thought.
Keep up the good work, Scott. thanks for being in touch. I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast.
If I put all the podcast files together into a single download, it's just a huge file.
With the help of backers and upgrading the website services, look forward to being
able to download podcasts in groups of 20, and that should help because a lot of people
have asked for that. And I would also direct you to the Scoutmaster CG app, and I'll be talking a
little bit more about that in a moment. We also heard from Barry Carney in Downingtown, Pennsylvania,
and he wrote in to say I enjoy listening to your podcast and the information you share with
other scouts. I'll soon apply all those pearls of wisdom and insights in my new position
when I become the Scoutmaster of Troop 2 here in Downingtown this winter.
I've already started to use them during the transition period. Most importantly, I'll never
forget the kindness that both you and your Troop showed to my son as a provisional scout
at summer camp for two years in a row. It really kept him motivated to complete his Eagle.
Keep up the great work. Well, thank you, Barry, and we remember your son very well- Wonderful guy,
and he was certainly a welcome addition to the Troop during those two weeks of summer camp.
and congrats on becoming a Scoutmaster. What a great thing. It's the leap into the volcano.
Best of luck, Barry, and we look forward to keeping up with you and hearing from you again.
Tony LaClova is in Bristow, Virginia, and he wrote in to say I love the podcast
and I listen to it every week. I really enjoyed your last book. I have my favorite lines marked
with sticky notes and I'm looking forward to getting the scouting journey very soon.
Both Barry and Tony have become backers too, but more about that in a moment. I did mention
the Scoutmaster CG app, and right now it's available for Android devices on Google Play.
We've had some feedback about it. since it's been out. We've kind of did, you know,
this kind of like soft launch, because app development is definitely new to me And
so we're trying to make sure that we get it all shaped up and everything as we go along.
But it's being used. and Chris Crowley said: left us a comment on Google Play, said:
Scoutmaster to the rescue. I love the app. No glitches as of yet, Smooth loading and all that.
Brian Monday said: finally, the app, The best Scouter blog in existence. Oh, come now,
Now easily accessible from my droid. David Copeland commented that it was an excellent
resource. It was going to be great. Every Scouter should use this resource for learning
and community. Van Donnelly said: great job, Clark. Nice first effort, Looking forward to
improvements on the app. So, on the app, you will eventually be able to get- as I have time to add
them- all of the past podcasts. They'll all be linked through the app. It's a there's a integral
player in the app makes it very, very easy to go back and listen to past podcasts. Greg Blackshaw
downloaded the app and worked with it for a bit and suggested that we add some resources like
infographics and PDFs that are commonly available on the site to the app, And so we've gone ahead and
done that. Let me know what you think of that page And I'm going to keep after it and keep adding
features and sorting things out. So, once again, it's only available for Android devices right
now. As soon as we have the resources, we'll get it up and going on iTunes too, so that you can
use it with iPhones and iPads, And I'll be sure to let you know about that. The backer program:
my goodness, I am pleased and, I have to say, frankly, touched, by the outpouring of support
that we've had since we launched the Scoutmaster CG backer program a couple of weeks ago.
You can become a backer by going to scoutmastercgcom. You'll see a link to the backer program.
There are some nice premiums that we're offering for those who offer financial support to the blog
and the podcast, And I want to welcome the new backers who've signed up in the past week:
Hoyt Kondra, Joseph Marty, Jay Manoscalo, David Kish, Dale Carwike, Lani Alperson, Kirk Swan,
Alexandria Keenan, Bill McFarland, Rob Knapp, Al Best, Jerry Kohler, Jeff Person, Anthony LaClaava,
Daniel Weeks, Scott Gata, Ed Bruce and Barry Carney. Thank you once again for your generous
support and to enable us to make things happen for our fellow Scouters. And, speaking of things
happening, the Scouting Journey, the new book that we've been talking about and talking about.
it's out there now. Yes, that's right. It is now available on Amazon, And what you're listening to
is the first announcement of that availability. So you can go to amazoncom, search for the
Scouting Journey and you'll be able to find it in both Paperback and Kindle editions. I'll put
a link to where you can find it on Amazon in the post that contains this podcast. But wow,
phew, it's done, It's out there and it's ready, And I really hope you enjoyed it. I'm anxious to
hear what you think about the new book. Well, in the remainder of this podcast, in Scout Mastership
in seven minutes or less, we're going to talk about evaluating positions of responsibility,
And then we've got some email questions to answer. So let's get started, shall we
Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less.
A perennial difficulty that Scouters run into is the evaluation of the positions of
responsibility that are part of the Star, Life and Eagle ranks. In one way, what I'm about to talk
about is very specific advice for those particular ranks in the Boy Scouts of America, But I think
there is a lot of things in general that we can apply what I'm about to say in Scouting.
We need to remember that evaluation of things like this in Scouting are not like anything else
And that's why we talk about it a lot And that's why it's hard to get
Our work and our professional lives as adults are attached to some sort of objective standard.
about 99% of the time Our Scouts in their lives, in school and in the things that they do in their
lives, are attached to some kind of objective standard. They get grades and things like that,
And when we get to Scouts there are things that just don't have an objective standard
And evaluating a position of responsibility is one of those things that causes problems sometimes.
So I want to take some time and talk about it because I get questions from adults who feel
like Scouts are skating by in their position of responsibility. They're not doing their job.
They get to the point where they evaluate that position of responsibility requirement for
star life and eagle and questions come up and it can cause a great deal of trouble.
But first of all, let's remember that positions of responsibility, leadership positions in Scouting
for youth, are opportunities. How can somebody skate by on one of these positions? I just
don't understand how it can happen. How long before someone like the Scout Master- this is a
specific responsibility of a Scout Master- talks to the young man and gets them to up their game.
How can we get to the point where a Scout takes on a position of responsibility and then some
months later the judgment comes that he didn't do very well? That means to me the Scout has
not failed, but the Scouters who are involved with the Scout have failed. I mean, have they talked
to the Scout during that period? Does the Scout understand what their position of
responsibility is? Do they know what to do? Do they understand that things aren't going so well?
Has anybody brought that to their attention? If they aren't showing up and not fulfilling
the responsibility, why is that On positions of responsibility, we just don't start a clock
and wait until it runs out before we're giving Scouts feedback and training and mentoring to
help them make the best of that opportunity? There should be no question in anyone's mind,
when a Scout has completed his tenure in a position of responsibility, that he's done his best,
because this is a subject of frequent and meaningful discussion with the Scout Master.
It's that simple. How does the Scout Master approach this? Well, I suggest you go way overboard
in pointing out what a wonderful job the Scout did. You do this honestly and frequently in front
of the Patrol Leaders Council, in front of your fellow Scouters and in front of the other Scouts
and watch what happens next. Every Scout with a position of responsibility will be paying
attention. They'll hear about the successes of their fellow Scouts and they will up their game.
If someone is actually kind of skating by, we find something positive about what they are doing
and we build on it. When I sit down and talk to a Scout where I am signing off their tenure in a
position of responsibility, I ask lots of questions. I ask them if they felt that they understood
what was expected of them, And the answer usually is well, not at first, but I began to get the
hang of it as time went by. I ask them to give me an example of what they were proud of about
their work, if there was anything that they regretted or that they would do differently.
I ask them if they think they met that requirement and what they plan to do next.
It is almost certain that there will always be at least one Scout in a position of responsibility
that we'll look at and we will consider to be kind of lackluster in performance and kind of
reluctant, Rather than concentrating on what they aren't doing. look for the 10% or the 5% that they
are getting right and build up on it. Now, if you do that and they go from 5 or 10% effort to 50%
effort during the time they spend in that position of responsibility, haven't we succeeded? Aren't
we getting out of scouting what we want to get out of it? Are we looking for progress or are we looking
for some certain standard of performance? When it comes to evaluating a position of responsibility,
there are no objective standards other than the individual Scout's effort. Let me read this
section to you from the new book: okay, The Scouting Journey- Imagine achieving a subjective
requirement- was a literal foot race and the finish line is an ideal standard. Not all Scouts begin
that race at the starting line. They begin at different places. They have different home lives,
characters and habits and these place them ahead of or behind their fellow Scouts.
Our average Scout with no outstanding advantages or deficits begins the race, let's say,
at the starting line. Scouts with greater advantages and skills in a given area
begin 75 yards ahead of the starting line. Scouts with little or no advantage or skill
or some real deficits, begin 50 yards behind the starting line. The starter's pistol
sounds, the Scouts are off and running and our gifted Scouts cover the short distance to the
finish line quickly. An average Scout covers 75% of the course. another covers 25% of the course.
The Scout who began the race well behind the starting line just reaches the starting line
before the race is over. So the question is: how much ground did each Scout cover?
The Scout who began farthest behind and only reached the starting line has progressed
further than the gifted Scout who reached the finish line. Our aim will always be the ideal
at the finish line, but our evaluation is about progress. Now, this aspect of Scouting is difficult
for a lot of us. It's very right in theory to require everyone reach the same finish line,
but that's not what we are after. We want all of our Scouts to progress. This is why subjective
requirements don't have objective standards. They're based on individual progress.
Now, absolutely not everyone thinks I have this right. They think we should set rigorous standards
and only reward Scouts who reach the ideal at the finish line. I'd agree with them if all of
our Scouts started at the same point. but they don't. They just don't. When called on to
make a subjective evaluation like this, we should ask our Scouts to evaluate themselves using their
own internal standard. The answer gives us all kinds of opportunities to strengthen how they think,
how they see themselves and how they encourage themselves to do better. When Scouts evaluate
themselves against their own best efforts rather than against the efforts of others
or some objective standard, they learn to find inner motivation and purpose. When we help them
exercise this internal standard, we enable Scouts to weave the Scout oath and law into their life
and character. They form a personal connection to the moral and ethical precepts of Scouting.
They learn that their internal motivations are more important than how others see us.
This type of thing, to me, is so very important. It's everything that we're aimed at as Scouters:
Developing people of character who know how to encourage themselves, who know how to look at
their efforts honestly and who have a positive outlook on life that's informed by the Scout
oath and law. If you're finding evaluating these kind of subjective things, like positions of
responsibility, like Scout Spirit and the other requirements that seem to cause a lot of trouble,
just remember we are in the business of development, not performance measurement.
We want all of our Scouts to progress but more importantly, we want them to learn those valuable
life skills embodied in the Scout oath and law by developing an internal standard by which
they can judge their own performance, encourage themselves and continue to do better.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
This first email comes in from a reader at scoutmastercgcom
and it will be readily apparent why their name is being withheld. They wrote in to say this.
we have a dilemma in our troop. Our son became an Eagle Scout back in March of this year. At
that time he was going on college searches so his court of honor was delayed. At this point
he is in college and he's 1200 miles away from home. We just learned both the Scout Master
and Committee Chair recently resigned from the troop. The chartering organization has taken charge
and assigned a new group of Scouters. This new group is kind of overwhelmed and the old Scouters
are upset by the circumstances that precipitated the resignation of the Scout Master and Committee
Chair and they're not exactly sure what happened. Apart from all of these politics and
difficulties, my son's Eagle Scout kit has apparently been misplaced. There's been a lot
of confusion and difficulty. it's sad to see and we really don't know what's going on. Our son
has heard about these developments and he's very upset too. His Eagle Court of Honor was tentatively
scheduled for January of next year, while he's home from college, but he's questioning whether he
really wants to go through with it after these changes were made to the troop leadership. I'm an
Eagle Scout myself and I'm curious to know what options we may have. My wife and I are trying
to figure this out as discreetly as possible At this point. our son would prefer gathering
his scouting friends and the leaders that helped him along the way for his Eagle Presentation.
Well, I'm sorry to hear that there's trouble. it happens from time to time.
but just to be clear, everything official has already happened so far as your son's Eagle is
concerned. A Court of Honor is an important thing, but it's nothing more than a meaningful
presentation of the award. There's no official anything that happens at a Court of Honor.
He was an Eagle Scout as soon as his Board of Review was over and the results of that
board were certified by the National Office. As far as the presentation of that award at a
Court of Honor, any Eagle should be able to decide what is meaningful to them and shape the
presentation as they like. You mentioned that the Eagle Kit and the associated letters and
certificates that come along with it seem to be missing at this point. So what I would
suggest is that you call your council office and locate the person who looks after Eagle
Scout paperwork, Explain exactly what you've explained to me in this email and ask if they
would be able to provide you with a new set of credentials and a new Eagle Kit.
Now you may have to wait on the credentials and pay for the replacement kit, depending on the
circumstances. While this isn't routine, it's not unknown for an Eagle Kit and the credentials
and the letters of congratulations to get lost. It's not unknown. You don't really need permission
or any official to have a presentation. You can choose the place and the time and the content
of the ceremony. Naturally, you'll ask your son what he would like and you'll do the best to make that
happen, because it's going to be difficult for him to arrange all these things from a distance.
I need to tell you that there's much more meaning and sense of moment in what is said at the
presentation. You know, all the trappings in the window dressing of a Court of Honor are nice,
but nobody really remembers those quite so much as they remember who was there
and what they said. I hope that helps. Shortly after receiving the last email, I received this one
and, for similar reasons. the name and the location of the person who sent it to me are being withheld.
The email reads: I have been reading your post, especially on scouts having problems with
their scout masters. I travel weekly for work so I am unable to participate in scouting with my
son. I have been very proud of him doing scouting completely on his own in most respects.
He's also a National Honor Society member and an excellent student, and we as parents
think he's a great guy. What my wife and I did not know until recently was our son was not
really enjoying scouts at all. He's one of three senior scouts in his troop who's working with
a large number of new scouts who've recently crossed over from Weeblos. A couple of years ago
the old scout master retired and a new one took over. My son began putting together
his Eagle Scout project this past spring. He consulted with an Eagle advisor from the
troop about a potential project. Over the course of several weeks the scout master
delayed the project by asking repeatedly for additional information, to the point where the
timeline of his original idea could not be met. So my son had to find a new project.
He started the approval process for the new project and the same delays began again.
It took two months until the scout master would actually sign off on his paperwork
so he could take it to the district where it was finally approved. Because of the repeated
questions about his drawings and plans, he built a prototype for the project. We sent a picture
of the prototype to his Eagle advisor and his advisor responded that he was going about things
all wrong, that he had to involve the troop and he had very specific demands about how this was
to be done. This is the point where our son finally came to me and his mother with his
concerns about the scout master and the Eagle advisor and the way they had been treating him.
He told us that they were not letting him lead his project and they were telling him how to manage it.
Since I was out of town, my wife spoke to both the scout master and the Eagle advisor but really
didn't get anywhere with them. I tried talking to both of them. I wasn't able to get anywhere
either. I reached out to the old scout master, who told me that this was a familiar story,
that other scouts had gone through the same thing with the present scout master,
that my son is now going through delays and criticism and frustration.
My son loves scouting and he really wants to become an Eagle scout. He's not been enjoying
his experience for the past year and now is actually afraid to talk to the scout master or
his advisor because they've treated him so poorly. I find this discouraging and heart-rending.
It came to the point where I had a discussion with my son and I told him
that he did not have to go back. He was visibly relieved. He has eight months until he turns 18..
He still wants to pursue becoming an Eagle scout. So my question for you is: can he switch
troops easily? He wants to complete scouts on a good note. Does he have to completely resubmit
his project, or will somebody just pick up where the old troop left off? I'm also curious
as to whether I should let anybody know about this situation. It seems to be happening to a
number of scouts and I feel as though, as a parent, it's my responsibility to bring it to
the attention of someone who can do something about it. That is a really sad story. Now,
fortunately, it's relatively rare. Unfortunately, it's not unheard of Why scout masters get into
this position. Why they create these situations is beyond me. If it was within my power to do so.
I would apologize on behalf of that adult, but unfortunately it's not within my power to do
that. What I can do is advise you that, yes, it is easy to switch troops. All you have to do is find a new
troop and transfer your membership. A troop has absolutely no hold on a scout. Scouts are
volunteers. They get to be involved where they want with who they want. I don't see any reason
that your son should have to resubmit his project or begin over again. If you find a troop that
knows scouting and is familiar with the Eagle process, he should be able to pick up right where he
left off and become an Eagle scout before he turns 18.. As for telling somebody about the problem,
I would suggest that you begin by talking to whoever is the head of the institution that
charters the scout troop In the way that the scouting works, that person has absolute authority
to direct the volunteers of the troop. If the troop was chartered by a church, that might be the
pastor, It might be somebody on the board of elders. It would be relatively easy to figure out.
You may want to raise your concerns with the district advancement chairman or the district
executive. They can encourage scouters, but the person who has absolute authority to direct
scouters is going to be the head of the chartering institution, And I probably don't have to tell you
this. but if you're going to raise these concerns, please arrange a face-to-face meeting. I know it's
difficult since you travel so much, but please don't do this over email. Emails can kind of take on a
life of their own and be misinterpreted and misunderstood. I do agree with you that,
as a responsible parent, it is important to raise these issues with people who can affect a change, if
need be. This email comes from Michael Harrington. I have noticed there doesn't seem to be a
requirement for too deep leadership at scout meetings. There's only a requirement for
too deep leadership on trips and outings. I do note the additional rule of no one-on-one
contact between adults and scouts. So it seems that as long as there are more than one scout
and one registered adult at a scout meeting, there's no problem. Is that correct or am I missing something?
Well, Michael, you're not missing anything. You've correctly interpreted what it says
in the Guide to Safe Scouting when it talks about scouting's barriers to abuse
and the idea of too deep leadership. So too deep leadership on all outings is required. Now that
means two registered adult leaders, or one registered adult leader and the parent of a participating
scout or other adult, one of whom must be 21 years of age or older. Those two people are required
for all trips or outings. You've also correctly expressed what the Guide to Safe Scouting says
when it talks about one-to-one contact between adults and scouts. One-to-one contact between
adults and youth members is not permitted In situations that require personal conferences,
such as a scout master's conference. the meeting is to be conducted in view of other
adults and scouts. Thanks for bringing that up, Michael. that's a common question, The best thing
to do when you have questions, folks. of course, you can email me, but run to the resource and the
Guide to Safe Scouting answers a lot of common questions. Make sure to get a copy and make
sure to read it. Justin Field is the scout master of Troop 89 in Downers Grove, Illinois.
He says: first, let me say that you've been an incredible resource for me personally as I continue
to make an attempt at improving myself as scout master. I jumped into the volcano in 2010 when
I was 25.. Well, Justin, we were similar ages but just a couple of decades apart when we started
our work as scout masters. He goes on to say: my biggest struggle has been getting our newest
parents informed about how scouting works. It's not that I mind talking about scouts, but sometimes
it seems like all I ever do. At our committee meeting last night, we discussed a new member liaison
and the idea of having a parents meeting about once a year. Historically speaking, these parents
meetings haven't worked so well. Most parents don't really show up, and the ones who do show up
were the ones who were already pretty familiar with scouting. So my question for you is: what can
I do? Well, Justin, communicating with parents is a big challenge for all of us. We need to let
them know what we're doing, and that's one challenge, But we want them to understand
why we do what we do, and that's an even bigger challenge. I'm working with my committee too,
and we're working on setting up a parents channel where someone from the troop is contacting
parents at least twice a month, kind of like a customer service representative. Our patrol
leaders are talking to their scouts each week, but that doesn't always filter through to parents.
It's going to be a challenge to do this so that we don't undermine our youth leadership,
but it's obvious that we're not doing a very good job of communicating the why behind the
how of what we do. So we're hoping to get four or five people trained to talk to parents in a way
that explains things without taking away from our youth leaders. They'll have some information
on hand about who does what and how things work, and you would think you know well why don't we
just create a big document and hand it to parents. but that's not going to work. It's got to be that
kind of closed loop communication where one person is actually talking to another person on a regular
basis. That's going to do the trick. You definitely aren't alone in this. This is a huge challenge
for all of us. The easy answer is involving the committee, but we need to make sure that we're
all on the same page, that the committee is working along with the scout master, otherwise
we're going to have lots of cross channels and misunderstandings. As for parents meetings,
those should be a little more frequent than once a year. We have a parents meeting combined with
a quarter of honor four times a year, every quarter, and, as you said, attendance at those can be spotty
and it's more likely that the people who already know what's going on show up and the people
who you wish knew more, do not? The answer for this is going to be direct communication. That's far as
I've been able to make out so far, Justin. I hope that helps, and I'll be interested to hear what
you decide to do and how it works. If you have a question, you can get in touch and you're
going to find out how to do that in just a moment. Well, thank you so much for listening to
this 197th edition of the scout master podcast. Here's how to keep in touch. read the scout master
blog at scoutmastercgcom While you're there. you can join 2700 other folks on our email
subscription list and get updates to the blog by email. You can subscribe to the scout master
podcast on iTunes or access the podcast on your mobile device through Stitcher smart radio,
and you can get details about how to do that at stitchercom. You can download the free scout master
cg app on google play and that'll give you access not only to the podcast but to the blog
and to the podcast archive. You can experience all the wonders of scoutmastercgcom through the
vast panorama of social media outlets. Join the 4400 folks who follow us at scoutmaster blog
on Facebook Tweet, along with our 880 Twitter followers at scoutmastercg on Twitter. You can
watch us at scoutmastercg on YouTube. You can join the 400 plus plusers- I guess that's the right way
to put it- At scoutmastercg on google plus and pin along with the 1200 folks who follow us
at Pinterest. Yes, Pinterest, who would have known it? But, Clark, you say I don't tweet, I don't
watch, I know plus and I don't pin. Well, that's all right, monkey, Zoom into the late 1990s and send me
an email. That's the easiest way to get in touch. Email me, Clark Green, at Clark CLA RKE
at scoutmastercgcom. You too can become a scoutmastercgcom backer. Get details about
how to do that at the website and take a look at the premiums that are offered for backers.
I need to tell you that the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America. and boy are they relieved.
And we're not sponsored or endorsed by the Boy Scouts of America. Hey, it's just me talking
into a microphone, trying to lend a hand to scout leaders and have a little bit of fun along the
way. And speaking of fun, here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert, Good luck to
you and good camping, Why? thank you, sir, until next time.